why was the decision taken with so
little notice
well because the cases in spain the data
we got was on the friday
you obviously compile that through the
course today it showed a big jump
right across mainland spain that was
then assessed uh yesterday afternoon
and we took the decision as swiftly as
we could and that we we can't
make apologies for doing so we must be
able to take
swift decisive action particularly in
relation to
uh localized or internationally in
relation to spain a particular country
where we see we must take action
otherwise
we risk reinfection into the uk uh uh
potentially a second wave here
and then another lockdown so yes i
understand it is
disruptive for those who are going
through this who are in spain or who
have been
considering going to spain we must
though we must be able to take swift
decisive action
to protect the uk because we've made
such progress getting the virus down
and to prevent uh the virus taking
retaking hold in the uk well i don't
think anyone would debate the need to
take fast action swift action on this
but at the same time
it really was pretty quick uh so the
foreign office travel advice for example
at 8 pm
last night said this that spain was on
the list of countries that british
people could travel to
these countries and territories have
been assessed as no longer presenting an
unacceptably high risk to british people
traveling abroad
spain is exempt from the foreign office
advice against all
non-essential international travel 8 pm
on saturday
would it not be useful to at least flag
to people that this was something under
consideration a lot of people travel on
saturday
no sorry that's that's just not right we
must be able to gauge the data in real
time which we did the data coming
through on friday
and then take decisive action if we
suddenly say
actually we're not quite sure or we give
vague advice it would create
more uncertainty so look i know and
there's a cutoff with changes in rules
or advice that we give
so i appreciate that that's difficult
and and it can be disruptive
but it'd be far worse either to muddy
the waters or to hold back and delay
from taking the measures when we need to
take them and of course the reason that
this was taken a
reasonably short notice was because the
spike in spain that we've responded to
came uh uh you know we were following
that and that's when it happened
so it was the real-time response the
data we were getting from spain that we
had to respond to very swiftly you don't
want uncertainty
but you know earlier this month we were
talking about a traffic light system for
example i mean is that not something
that could be considered that could be
used
well and let's not conflate seo travel
advice with the quarantine rules they're
decided separately although similar
factors taken into account
but i think it i think above all uh
people that are traveling or considering
traveling need certainty and clarity
and the flip side of that is of course
uh we need to take those decisions
you could use an alert system you know
red amber green couldn't you well i
think with amber what would we be
actually saying
people want to know whether they can go
whether they should go where they
shouldn't and the
the system that we've had in place and
we've had various crises we've had to
deal with before
is tailored to be able to give people
clear and decisive
advice of course and again i just want
to come back and say so
if we can't take these targeted measures
we've had to take them in relation to
leicester at home
we've had to take them in relation to to
holiday and travel to spain
we can't do that we've always said as we
come through the lockdown
and come out of lockdown we would need
to take targeted measures if we can't do
that
the risk is the virus gets back hold in
the uk the damage to the economy of a
second lockdown and i think the blow to
public confidence
so yes these measures um are decisive
and swift
and as a result of that inconvenient for
those going through them i
would totally emphasize with that but
they're absolutely necessary
how are you going to enforce it which
bit of it well the fact that people need
to stay at home for two weeks
well as the same way as we said
throughout we've got the
14 days quarantine it is required
and there are penalties for for there's
not really any way you can check us
there
well we look we throughout this crisis
we have and we've one of the reasons
we've been effective
in getting the virus down is people have
followed the advice
so there is you're absolutely right to
say there's an element of personal
responsibility but it is also backed up
by very clear
law and sanctions in relation to
non-compliance um now if you have got a
holiday
booked in spain in the next couple of
weeks lots of people will have
yeah are you gonna get your money back
well the way it works is that the
insurance companies respond to the
changes in travel advice if we've
upped holiday makers to get in touch
with their insurance companies but we're
very clear now that we advise against
travel to mainland spain
okay and of course it's difficult for
the travel industry as well a sector
already on its knees before this has
happened
more pressure put on them and just want
to have a look at what tui
has said in reaction to your uh decision
the managing director we're incredibly
disappointed that we didn't get more
notice of this announcement
or that this decision wasn't made
yesterday as many brits travel on
holiday
at the weekend uh going on to say the uk
government must work closely with the
travel industry
is this level of uncertainty and
confusion is damaging the business when
you say you want to avoid uncertainty
but from what the travel industry is
saying this really is creating
uncertainty too isn't it well
i've got no doubt that the airlines are
going through a very difficult patch
but look we got the data on the spike on
the friday we evaluated it and changed
the advice
on the saturday we couldn't have
responded more swiftly more decisively
and of course i take into account the
the challenges the airlines are going
through
the passengers going to spain but we've
also got to keep in our mind the big
picture here
and let's remember that the virus
originally coming into the uk
part of that was from travel from europe
so should their quarantine have been
imposed at the beginning then
no what we're saying is that that having
got and this was the advice all along
having got the virus down now
we've made huge progress the number of
cases the number of deaths number of
people in hospital
the risk of reinfection or reviving the
virus
from abroad is at such a level that we
need to be able to take
these targeted measures and the reason
we're able to
do that and still allow people to go
abroad in areas which aren't subject to
the change advice
is because we're taking targeted
measures where there's risks from
a country like spain or particularly
mainland spain does sound like a useful
thing to be doing at the early part of
the year then now i just want to talk
about i'm sorry
sorry so you sort of snuck that in there
the point the advice has consistently
been
that you take the quarantine measures
when the virus level in your country is
down
to such a level that yeah which is why
i'm saying it should have been done at
the beginning of the year when as you
were saying the vast has been brought in
from europe
no no sorry it would have it would have
made its way
uh i'm afraid once the virus had
exploded globally in the way that it had
i think
well not if we were quarantining people
but we wouldn't have known beforehand
and none of the advice from the
scientists or the chief medical officers
that
their advice is but it's just really
important it's been consistently it's
when you brought the virus down in the
uk
that the risk of reinfection from abroad
goes up that's precisely why we've taken
the measures we have
now the department of transport is
asking employers to be
understanding of people who need to
quarantine for two weeks through no
fault of their own
i mean it sounds a little bit like
you're just asking nicely
hoping for the best don't you need to be
a little bit more forceful than that oh
look we're
changing the rules the law is changed in
relation to holiday makers and
travellers
and of course we expect uh the employers
show those employees who will have to
quarantine because of the law the
flexibility they need
what if you don't have an understanding
employer if you have an understanding
employer that's totally fine but not
everyone does i mean that's what we saw
in leicester isn't it you know
frankly when you were hoping that
employers would do the right thing
some business in leicester were clearly
not enforcing the social distancing
rules and that led to a spike in
infection
what if you don't have an understanding
employer well look employers just like
employees have got to follow the law and
i don't think you could
be laying people off or taking penalties
against people foreign
i think we're talking about not paying
people if you're on a zero hours
contract not giving them work
sorry if if someone has followed the law
in relation to
um quarantine and self-isolating the way
they should they can't have penalties
taken against them
well you could be put on a 92 pound six
pay couldn't you a week
rather than getting uh paid leave you
could not be given work if you're in new
zealand
you cannot be penalized in this country
lawfully for following the rules
and the law that's in place and
obviously we expect employers
to respond flexibly and an understanding
way to those who have let's face it had
enforced on them
because of the risk that we've seen in
spain those quarantine rules
okay now spain of course isn't the only
place where we've seen
a rise in cases if you look at places
like france germany belgium they've all
seen
an increase in coronavirus cases uh
are we likely to see other countries
taken off the safe list for travel in
the same way
well look as we've found with spain we
can't give a guarantee what we can say
is that we've got this joint
biosecurity center as you can see we we
monitor the risk in real time we take
decisive swift action um
and so there is an element of
uncertainty this summer as people uh go
abroad and that's why
our advisors follow the foreign office
travel advice which will also link into
the quarantine principles
look very carefully at doing that should
you really be looking at staycations is
that what you're going to be doing on
holiday this year
well i'm not going to tell people what
they should and shouldn't do they should
follow the advice i'm going to be
staying at home
uh this summer but we've got lots on uh
so
that's a personal decision really okay
what was your
reaction when you heard that the
transport secretary had been trapped by
his own quarantine
i think it shows you um the the risks
for everyone
uh i spoke to grant chaps uh yesterday
afternoon
um and it shows you that we've got swift
measures
uh that we can put in place responding
to real time what mood was here
i think look um like anyone i think he
empathized with many other people going
through that
um but he recognized of course and we as
the decision makers recognize that we
have to take these measures
to protect the country and as we eat
come through the easing of the lockdown
we've always said when you look at the
strategy you look at what we said all
along
we need to be able to take targeted
measures when there's a flare up in the
virus
and being able to do it in a localized
way stops us having to do it in a
nationwide way
when um when did grant shouts travel to
spain i don't know
you don't know so you don't know if he
knew this was coming i mean it's one way
to avoid media interviews i guess
two weeks in question i'm pretty sure he
didn't do it for that purpose
but you'd need to ask grant about his
travel plan okay uh now parliament is
breaking for
the summer recess um and it does feel as
if august is absolutely critical
for the government to get battle ready
for a potential second spike
in the awesome month in the winter
months when the weather gets colder when
there's already more pressure on the nhs
yes because if you look at the most
recent test and trace statistics
you do have to question if we're ready
right now so according to the office of
national statistics
2 800 new cases a day but in the last
week of test and trace published only
3098 people who
tested positive were reached and asked
to provide details of their contacts i
mean that is thousands of people
who we're not reaching it's not good
enough is it look the the
testing capability is ramped up it's uh
over i think 300 000 now
daily but that's not how many we're
actually testing and and the ability to
trace
um is ramped up and is being applied i i
looked at the
statistics earlier on in the week i
don't know the ones that you're
referring to
but you're right we're keeping ramping
up the prime minister now said we want
the testing
capability to go up to 500 000 and i
think your broader point is right and
you've heard from matt hancock
as we and that's one of the reasons
we're taking the measures like with
quarantine to make sure we use the
summer months
to to invest in the nhs make sure for
example on flu and all the other
non-covered pressures
that we're in a good place as we go into
the autumn and into the winter months
where there is a risk
but we're well prepared for that the
money's going in the preparedness
is going in and we're also making sure
we're providing the support for
businesses and
uh and livelihoods as we go through you
mentioned the testing capacity there now
uh yesterday
at 9am the most uh recent figures showed
a capacity of 2
800 280 000 tests but we only used 157
000 so i guess my question is why aren't
we using full capacity
the interviewer tony blair for example
he called for mass testing
he said i still don't think we've got
the right strategy in place for mass
testing
if you think our capacity is 300 000
tests a day the point that you made
we're probably only utilizing about half
of that maybe slightly more than that
but
we soon have 500 000 tests a day
capacity we should be using all of it
why aren't we using all of our capacity
why don't we just test people coming
back from spain to see if they've got it
so they don't have to isolate well i
think
uh it is right to take a more targeted
measure but obviously if you've got the
virus or
i think he's saying not more targeted i
think he's saying mass testing on
targeted
we are as as we you know i remember the
original 100 000
uh testing capacity target then it was
up to 200 thousand now 300
000 and we're aiming for 500. we're
talking about how many people are
testing so i understand
the proportion the proportions have gone
up and it's not just important for the
testing it's also the tracing
so if you look at this over say two or
three months we've made a quantum leap
in terms of progress but you're right we
we've got further to go and it is
crucial
as part of the easing of the lockdown
but also as we
approach the autumn and then winter
months but that is a key bit of the
infrastructure we need in place but
we've made huge progress as we have
frankly with getting the number of cases
the number of deaths down so we're
look we're in reasonable shape here
we're in good shape in terms of
coming through in our preparedness
obviously it's been a huge loss of life
but if you look at the approach that
we're taking
and particularly this question of easing
up but making sure you can always yank
the handbrake back on as we've had to do
regrettably
in relation to spain as we've done with
in relation to leicester
that is what makes sure that we can make
steady progress forwards
now one of the other things that needs
to be in better shape according to boris
johnson is
all of us we need to be losing weight in
order to try and make sure that we're
not
so susceptible to some of the worst uh
cases of
coronavirus and what should we be
expecting from the obesity strategy
published soon
well i can't uh trail the uh the details
of the announcement that will be made
shortly what i can say is look we know
that a beast is related to
the worst outcomes from the virus the
prime minister himself came through
a very uh close run thing with
coronavirus he came out saying you know
what i've really got to get
in better shape uh look aft and we've
all got to do a bit more of that i think
health-wise across the country lifestyle
decisions things like that we need to
take some more personal responsibility
for that but government's got a role to
play as well
so i think it is something when we think
about the pressures on the nhs
we can all as members of uh society
both for our own sake but also for the
contribution that we make the pressures
on the nhs
think a little bit more about how much
exercise we take what we eat
uh what we drink and all those sorts of
things i mean i i'm not
you know many people are myself included
need to be thinking about those sorts of
things
well then yeah do you know what i sort
of seem to eat my way through the first
half of lockdown and then i lost a bit
of weight
uh in the second half because i was
starting to think about it a bit more
but i think more generally we do need to
take some personal responsibility and we
know one of the things coronavirus has
done
is shown how obesity can worsen health
impacts not just because you're
overweight you don't feel so good
but your exposure to disease is like
this pandemic um and just finally i just
want to talk about scottish
independence the support for scottish
independence has been ticking up
uh we heard from tony blair uh recently
uh a few moments ago saying boris
johnson is not going to be the person
who's going to save the union
67 of scots thinks that he's doing a bad
job
do you think boris johnson could be the
person who breaks the union no not at
all i think
if you look at the approach we're taking
we want to be making it really
clear the impact that the united kingdom
has as a government as a country
in all parts of the uk and that includes
in scotland and actually
if you look at uh coronavirus uh yes of
course we've got devolved settlement but
in terms of ppe
testing uh the role of the military they
had a huge impact in scotland are you
worried about independence
well look i always want to make sure
we're one united kingdom
and we get this debate we keep coming
back to it but i think that if you look
at the economic benefits
you look at the cultural togetherness if
you look at our clout on the
international stage we're much better as
one united kingdom
i think what we do need to do is much
more powerfully make the positive case
for it i think if you look at
referendum's elections recently there's
a bit of project fear that crept into
all of them
i think we need to be more full-throated
uh heartfelt in making the positive case
for the union and i certainly know what
a successful lead campaign is and i
and i think boris johnson is singly well
placed because of that optimistic
fizz that he has about himself uh and
his leadership style to make the case to
the union that way